il a réussi à enregistrer un nouveau
record de décès dus aux comics 19 depuis
le début de l'été le pays fait face à
une résurgence de l'épidémie en cause le
variant delta on en parle avec notre
cause mon à moscou vera goffman
un nouveau pic de décès aujourd'hui en
russie 8 115 morts ces dernières 24
heures hier le triste record s'élevait à
808 personnes décédées c'est le deuxième
jour consécutif où le nombre de décès
dépasse le ce de 800 personnes
parallèlement les hospitalisations les
contaminations continue à baisser la
russie enregistre aujourd'hui vingt-deux
mille nouveaux cas de corona virus dont
près de 2500 à moscou la descente de la
courbe des hospitalisations a permis au
maire de la capitale de lever ce matin
une série de restrictions dans la
capitale dont le télétravail les
entreprises ne sont plus obligés de
tester régulièrement leurs employés ni
de leur prendre la température toutes
les quatre heures selon l'édile sept
mille lits sont occupés par des malades
du coronavirus c'est un record minimum
depuis le début du mois d'avril quant au
nombre de personnes vaccinées il vient
de dépasser 4,5 millions de moscovites
soit entières de la population de la
capitale je vous propose d'écouter et
ont réfléchi à tous les pour et les
contre et consulter les spécialistes
j'estime qu'il est possible de passer à
l'étape d'assouplissement des
limitations sanitaire au cours des
dernières semaines nous avons effectué
plusieurs étapes d'allègement des
restrictions et de manière générale
moscou est déjà revenu à un rythme de
vie habituel
nous continuerons d'agir avec prudence
en nous basant sur l'analyse de la
situation actuelle et des prévisions
quant à l'évolution de la pandémie
serviès vanina tout de même souligné que
les autorités ont annulé pas les gestes
barrière l'interdiction d'organiser des
événements de masse ainsi que les
limitations des spectateurs pour les
théâtres les salles de concert et de
cinéma